I think in many ways self-love is the
starting point to world class and you've
never heard me say that before but the
way you are in the world is a deep
reflection of the way you are with
yourself you know your prosperity and
your income is always a reflection of
your self-identity your daily behavior
is always a reflection of your deepest
beliefs you're not going to go on the
world and represent your highest
creativity productivity and Mastery if
you hate yourself you're not gonna be
kind to people on the street smile at
strangers uplift the teammate wow a
customer if you're full of hatred about
who you truly are and I think this is
one of the missed ideas and one of the
missed truths in the world today the
doorway to success really does open
inward it doesn't open outward hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I was
making 300 bucks a month I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was studying the stories of
super successful entrepreneurs so I hope
that this story today helps give you the
motivation you need because I still
needed to myself so today let's live
your best believe life and learn the six
steps to change your life enjoy
so let me walk you through four specific
truths that will help you grow self love
number one honor your specialness honor
your specialness look we've got billions
of people on this tiny planet and yet
there is no other person alive today
quite like you no one quite like the the
gifts that you have no one quite like
the way that you talk no one has the
same fingerprints no one walks exactly
in the same way as you
no one has the same hopes and dreams as
you no one has had the same sufferings
that you have no one has become
precisely the same person that you are
no one has the same potential you have
no one has exactly the same Primal
genius that lurks at your core that
makes you special now I'm not suggesting
that you fall into what I call Ram
syndrome w-ram world revolves around me
look I'm so special I'm entitled I am so
special world give me a great living I
see that all over the world we live in
this Society of great entitlement people
don't want to show up early people are
not committed to Mastery in all cases a
lot of people are like give to me and
there become takers from their
organizations and their marketplaces and
their society versus understanding you
get from the world what you give to the
world but the point on this first truth
is honor your special less appreciate
Who You Are there is no one quite like
you
in truth to grow self-love is to do hard
things daily and I want you to think
about this one really intimately right
here right now
when you get up every day
are you on the path of least resistance
I you know someone said to me on one of
my social feeds the other day Robin I've
read the 5 a.m Club loved the
information full of energy to get it
done but I need to tell you it sounds
very easy it's much harder to do in real
life
well
what is this love we all have in this
world we live in of things needing to be
easy Society has sold us a bill of goods
you know everything should be easy we
should transform our health with one
quick pill you know a great relationship
should happen in a month and if we don't
have a magical relationship we're not
all in love and wonder then we should
leave the relationship if we're at a job
you know anything that's worth doing is
challenging at first and if we're at a
job oh after three months if it's not
the job of my lifetime we leave it in a
relationship you know if it's not
perfect we leave it
if we want to upgrade our health oh I've
been at it two weeks oh you know what
it's really hard I need to stop my
journey to world-class Fitness what's my
point my point is simply this anything
great you will ever do in your life is
hard
and so are you living every day let me
ask you right now in this moment I am
blessed to share with you when you get
up in the morning
when you go through your day when you
construct your evening routine is it all
around the path of least resistance is
it all about pleasure is it all about
fun is it all about are you a master of
easy or are you doing what the very few
do on the planet today as you know one
of my core brain tattoos is to have the
results 95 of the population do not have
you've got to commit to doing what only
five percent of the population are
willing to do and what the Titans do
what the virtuosos do what the
exceptionalists do
they build their days around the pursuit
of difficult things and if you do that
here's what happens you're going to
build momentum and if you do that each
day will be a platform for growth but
even more importantly how do you build
self-respect it's by doing difficult
things when you say
I'd like to watch a video in the evening
or my favorite TV show but tonight I
commit to spending time with my child
who wants my attention and who needs me
you grow in self-respect when you say
I'm going to get up at 5am I'm going to
run this 20 20 20 formula that Robin
teaches and that has literally helped
millions of people upgrade their morning
routine and their energy productivity
creativity impact
you grow in self-respect when you say
I'm not going to Coast through my day
today I'm going to do something that's
going to give me a micro win so my work
and my crafts gets a little better
you grow in self-respect if each day you
do difficult things and make these daily
optimizations each day through the doing
of micro difficulties
you build
greater self-respect and as you build
greater self-respect you fall in love
with yourself it's a great way to build
self-love I mean one of the tactics to
remember is how do you grow self-love
you consistently make and then keep self
promises which brings you and I to the
third truth to grow self-love go to the
woods go to the woods we spend so much
time in the noise of life we forget
about the signal we spend so much time
in the frenzy of society where forget
about who we truly are I'm challenging
you with great love and respect don't
just be a producer be a philosopher
don't just be out in the world go to the
Wilderness we are animals we need to
retreat but also at our core we must
spend time in solitude for years I've
been teaching a philosophy the 3s
philosophy Solitude silence and
Stillness Solitude silence and Stillness
in this world right now of such digital
distraction such social media comparison
such busy being busy we wake up in the
morning sometimes there's so many emails
so many notifications we must make the
time to go to the woods physically or
metaphorically and when you find that
time to practice the three s's of
Silence Solitude and Stillness here's
what happens you remember who you truly
are you remember your priorities you can
build intimacy and fluency with your
primary relationship and the primary
relationship I suggest to you who you
truly are
you're not your past you're not your
weaknesses you're not your false beliefs
you're not your hypnosis you're not your
Genius betrayals when you start to spend
time alone in the woods in solitude in
reflection that's when you can say I am
not my wounding
I am not my hatred I am not my
insecurity I am not my sorrow I am not
my fears I am not my stumblings
you start to
hear the quiet Whispers of your greatest
self and you start to remember you are
Luminosity you were a hero you're not a
victim you're a leader you have this
goodness within you this deep creativity
within you this great power within you
that longs to see every day and the more
you spend time in the woods alone
remembering who you truly truly are it's
like any other relationship you spend
time with it you nurture it you grow it
you become aware of it
it gets stronger and stronger and then
you become this force of nature out in a
world of so many people who have
forgotten who they truly are and you
stand as an army of one of possibility
and Leadership and strength
fourth truth to grow self-love is simply
this the more people you help the more
love you'll grow the more people you'll
help the more you will expand
if you really want to times 25 your
self-love times 25 your commitment to
impact you know Mother Teresa said it
really well it's as you help more people
you love yourself even more greatly
and it's Martin Luther King Jr and I'll
paraphrase him he said you know
we all can be great
because greatness is not about education
greatness is not about your position
greatness is not about your past every
single day we all can be helpful and so
each day we all can become great
and so I found personally the more I
shift the focus off of any any elements
of Fame Fortune applies getting more
likes and the more I obsess and make it
this mono maniacally
driven mission
that doesn't come from the ego that
comes from
servanthood to help more people through
the information I share in the world the
more joy I see in my own life
the more
I pursue helpfulness
the more
peace I fill up with
and this episode is certainly not about
me this episode is all about you I just
want to share my own personal experience
which is the more I get the focus and
Spotlight off of any personal rewards
and really not only intellectually but
emotionally where real transformation
comes from from the heart set that's why
it's so important a strong mindset
without a pure heart set is an empty
Victory and when you do that heart set
work so that you turn down the voice of
the low-grade emotions like anger and
shame and guilt and sorrow and when you
upgrade your commitment to self-love and
gratitude and servanthood it's amazing
what rewards you'll start to see in your
own life step number two is be true to
yourself with David Goggins every
morning I would shave my head thanking
God I'll reflect back on some of the
lies I may have told somebody or some of
the ways I acted I didn't feel
comfortable doing and I did it to
impress other normal people
the keyword there is normal everyday
people I was trying to make other people
like me how pathetic is that
so I this mirror would always tell me my
like my reflection would say God you are
a pathetic man
how does that feel every day to be this
way so I would just start having myself
accountable how how did I attack today
how did I attack yesterday
and if I didn't do something I was proud
of I write down the sticky note
and I would fix it
so then my senior year in high school
it was a totally different David Goggins
can you give an example of something
that you wrote down and fixed all right
there was a lunch table that I you know
I wanted to set the cool guy lunch table
man I wonder you know even though
everybody's calling me a [ __ ] all the
time I wanted to to try to act like
somebody I wasn't so I could fit in
and I sold my soul to the devil
you know trying to act like no I'm I'm
David Goggins that's who I am and so I
wrote down on a piece of paper
the table
sit by yourself
and that's what I did and guess what
happened
my table
became a table people started sitting at
because a whole bunch of people in that
lunchroom
felt exactly like I did I I launched
your list of things that I just I I
write down in this fix
so I write it down to fix it were there
things that you look to for
um
Role Models people that you were like
taking ideas from like why pull your
pants up if that's the popular style
like what was giving either you were the
single most insightful person I've ever
met which by the way is entirely
possible having listened to enough of
your material
or like you had a treasure Trove of
people that gave you great ideas even if
they were like fictional or movie or you
know athletes or whatever but
it was funny man one movie I watched all
the time was Rocky
great choice Rocky one
and I related to Rocky a lot because of
uh kind of you know weren't a smart guy
just tried real hard and the one scene
that I related a lot of my life too
still to this day
was Rocky one round 14.
and this is where I got taken Souls from
if you look at round 14 of Rocky one
Apollo is beating this out of Rocky
Rocky falls down this corner Mickey's
saying stay down stay down Rocky didn't
hear a soul Apollo after he knocked him
down turns around hands in the air like
I finally knocked down this animal right
Apollo doesn't know it but Rocky's
getting up
Apollo turns around the second Rocky
gets up
and Apollo looks at Rocky any Apollo
looks at him
with the look of like Rocky just took
his soul he Apollo shakes his head and
Rocky has his gloves and emotions
towards Apollo come on I'm still here
and this song comes on that I played so
when I brought the the Guinness book of
world's records it took me 17 hours
to do four thousand Thirty pull-ups I
listened to one song for 17 hours
two minutes and 17 seconds
I listen to that song for 17 hours
non-stop on repeat
so the image in my mind of a man was not
one that had
earrings sagged his pants I I had this
image in my head
and I was going to fulfill that
and I I didn't do any Trends I stopped
trending I stopped being this guy who
whatever was new
if that's not what I believe in I'm
doing this this is what I want to be
this is what I'm going to be step number
three is release your anger with Lisa
Nichols
[Music]
one of the first steps to releasing
anger is to understand the power of
anger
you know anger is an emotion that brings
with it uh so much anxiety stress it's a
shutdown emotion it literally is a
shutdown emotion and it's an emotion
that we never invite in it's very
intrusive it intrudes and it it causes
us it causes us to be smaller than we we
want to be it causes us to not stand in
our glory and in our greatness it causes
us to be absent of Love or absent of you
know Peace of Mind anger doesn't live
with those things it's like oil and
water and so to truly understand the
power of anger you have to first
understand the power of forgiveness so
let me first explain to you what
forgiveness isn't because most people
won't forgive because they have an
incorrect understanding of what
forgiveness is so forgiveness is not
partnering someone's Behavior it's not
excusing someone's Behavior forgiveness
isn't admitting that you were wrong
forgiveness isn't saying what was done
to me is okay
forgiveness isn't any of those things
forgiveness actually if you really
understand it it has less to do with the
other person and more to do with you and
more to do with your future let's go
back to the oil and water scenario so
forgiveness invites in love invites in
possibility invites in prosperity it
invites in new thinking it invites in
creativity so forgiveness is an
expanding emotion when you forgive
you're opened up for new things
anger is a Contracting emotion it
requires you to shut down to avoid to
shut out to stop talking everything in
Anger is about stopping and shutting
down
everything about forgiveness is about
opening up without pardoning someone's
Behavior I want to make sure I'm clear
on that because most people attach
forgiveness to it but you don't know
what he did but you don't know what she
did when you can detach forgiveness is
not about what they did forgiveness get
this forgiveness is about making
yourself available think about your body
is primary real estate there's only so
much of it it's a finite it's a finite
space there's only so much space it's
not forever this is your body this so if
this is your primary real estate if this
is your primary real estate your heart
and you're you have anger occupying 20
of it you can never experience a hundred
percent love you can never experience a
hundred percent possibility you haven't
given yourself a chance at a hundred
percent of the things you want most
because your primary real estate your
heart your body your mind is being
occupied with a very intrusive toxic
emotion
less and less about them
nothing to do with them being right or
their behavior being pardoned or the
action it's your your future is paying
for your past
when you hold on to anger
so when you get really connected to the
cost of anger
then it's not about the what
a matter of fact the longer you've been
angry the longer you've robbed yourself
of a hundred percent of what you were
worthy of and if someone's betrayed you
if someone's hurt you then you over
everyone deserve a hundred percent love
a hundred percent possibility a hundred
percent but it requires forgiveness and
in many cases it's forgiveness of
yourself in many cases the person you've
been angry at the longest is yourself
and the same rule applies when it comes
to you
so when you ask the question how do I
overcome anger when I've been angry for
so long
first
admit that you're tired of being angry
because something is familiar doesn't
mean you like it
and a lot of times we get resigned in a
familiar emotion just because it's
familiar doesn't mean it's the emotion
of choice it doesn't mean it's the
familiar doesn't mean favorite
it just means familiar
and so if you're willing to exchange
your familiar emotion for a an emotion
of possibility an emotion that you
deserve and emotion that you want more
then you will separate from the person
you will redesign your relationship with
anger in and of and by itself so I say
anger is going to come
I get angry anger just doesn't have
permission to take up real estate in
your primary it doesn't have permission
to take up any of your primary real
estate anger will come and as the in the
as fast as it comes in begin to do the
work it doesn't magically disappear
begin to do the work which is why you're
here on this channel
begin to do the work to allow anger to
keep on moving because when anger comes
and stays now you're inside of a
reservoir you're not a reservoir you
want to let anger keep moving like a
river
it will come but it also has to go
because there's something else on its
way to you there's love there's
possibility there's excitement there's
joy there's peace of mind and it has to
have space
to sit and be with you and you deserve
that the bottom line is you deserve to
Live Without Anger occupying let me say
that in a more powerful way you deserve
to live with peace of mind and joy and
possibility and love
you deserve to live with peace of mind
possibility love and joy and not at 50
and not at 85 percent at 100 based on
the life you've lived and What you
climbed over what you've gone through
what you've the mountains you've had to
make bow down you deserve love like
nobody else you deserve joy and peace of
mind beyond what you've ever seen and so
in order to give yourself the absolute
the absolute opportunity to get all you
deserve
don't let her stay close
trust me I know personally also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there Step number four is build real
confidence with Ed mylett what would the
steps to building real confidence yes
okay not just fake not just the fake
stuff not just the like oh I've got
muscles and I'm cool now it's like what
really helped you become really
confident because you you exude real
confidence wow thank you because that is
something I certainly lacked I think
anything you get really great at in life
that's out of necessity I mean I needed
it I was I was such an insecure little
boy so shy and I would say even into
early adulthood even into when I walked
into McKinley that was a very insecure
shy
um lacking self-confidence man and so I
had to build these tools so the first
thing I would say to you is clearly this
thing I said earlier about just
beginning to stack the pattern of
keeping the promises that I make to me
is a huge thing huge thing but I'll give
you secondarily identity is kind of like
that thermostat on the wall right there
there's a thermostat that thermostat
regulates the temperature of this room
so it's pretty cold outside today
actually it's still 73 degrees in here
the external conditions don't change the
regulated temperature your identity your
self-worth the values and truths you
hold to be true about yourself are your
personal identity they regulate your
life they're a thermostat setting and so
regardless of what external things
happen you see if it's really cold
outside there this room turns the heater
on Heats it back up to 73. if it's super
hot outside it will cool it back down to
73 degrees it's not the external
conditions it's the internal thermostat
that governs your life it will govern
everything that's why often in your life
you'll get life going maybe you've got
really fit for a while or you've made a
bunch of money and then all of a sudden
you wake up six months later and you're
back at that weight again you don't want
and you're financially back where you
were you've turned the air conditioner
back down to get life comfortable where
you believe you deserve it so this thing
regulates everything you can have
everything else in your life together if
you're a 73 degree or Fitness or faith
or happiness or money you are going to
get 73 degrees eventually just like this
room how do I alter it I believe in the
power of other human beings so I'm a
spiritual person I'm a praying man and I
believe God uses other people to alter
our thermostat so I became I mean
meticulous crazy I've told you three
times today intentionally I want to
spend more time with you
the reason is is I believe you help me
with my thermostat in certain areas so
what I did my recipe was keeping the
promises I made to myself and adding
people close to my proximity who could
alter those temperature settings in the
area so I have a lot of forget wealth I
have a lot of really happy people I
surround myself with because they they
through Association raised me to 80 and
85 and 90 degrees of Happiness if you
want to increase your faith you all have
seen this if you're around incredibly
faithful spiritual people your internal
thermostat changes same with money you
can't be around super fit people in your
proximity and not eventually become more
fit through proximity so mine has been
proximity of people that raise my
temperature setting step number five is
beat your fears with Brendan burchard
beat back those fears I've got four big
ideas for you and you're gonna love them
number one and you're gonna hate this
one I'll make sure you like the rest
number one
stop thinking the reason you are not
getting ahead has anything whatsoever to
do with fear
fear gets too much play in our lives
we're always going to it we're always
blaming it oh it's fear fear held me
back well I'm worried about this so I
stop and you know what it is it's a
grand lie that's been perpetuated by
Society it's a huge lie because look
fear real fear is physical fear
especially is there's an external threat
that's imminent and it's in your face
that's fear everything else is a
self-contrived story that we tell
ourselves and we need to realize that
most fear is just bad management of our
minds but we allow ourselves to Loop it
what happens if you don't know it
psychologically what's happening fear is
really just saying what if followed by a
negative statement what if she rejects
me what if they don't give me the
promotion I ask what if I fail what if
they make fun of me what if I lose
everything I work so hard for
what if followed by a negative statement
I have a question for you though what if
you started focusing more in your life
on the what ifs followed by a positive
statement what if she says yes what if I
get what I finally deserve what if I can
grow this business what if I can
accomplish that what if I believed in
myself again and you started stewing on
the positive as much as you've stood on
that old negative it would change your
story it would change how you feel about
yourself
fear is usually not the thing holding
people back what's usually holding them
back is the connection with
something more important than fear
let me say it again fear is not usually
what's holding people back
what's holding it back is a lack of
connection with something that's bigger
than fear stop blaming the fear my
friend this is a big thing for me I stop
you know what I I probably started
shooting videos
about two years after I should have
because I thought well what if they make
fun of me what if no one watches them
you know I wasn't a good communicator
this like I'm doing now I don't have a
teleprompter I don't have a couple
bullet points in front of me I'm
teaching you from my life from my
experience of of serving millions of
people around the world I I didn't have
that ability before
so I sat there for years worried and not
ready to start
and it was too unfortunate I mean I wish
I'd started earlier but back then it was
well what if it doesn't work what if
this is stupid and then finally I said
you know what
this isn't fear there's no fear
preventing me from going around and
pressing the red button on that camera
there is no fear there's no fear there
there's a story there there's a what if
followed by the negative statement there
but there's no fear there is no lie in
between me and the video camera it's my
own self stopping me it's my own lack of
commitment to something bigger than that
red button
stop telling yourself it's fear my
friend and that will change everything
in your life number two and this is huge
huge huge
if you don't believe anything I just
said then fine get a piece of paper and
write down the real fears
all write them down
don't you think of the dream that you
have the ambition the goal and any
reason that you think you've been
stopping write down why okay what would
you have to go learn
do or ask for in order to overcome that
fear or that challenge
it's simple you know the biggest
breakthrough sometimes for people's
lives is when they write stuff down have
you ever had that you've been in a
seminar and you're right in your Journal
pow the idea hits you or you're writing
your Journal at night or you're typing
your book or you're doing something and
just by the act of expression or
capturing you find your answers so if
I'm talking to you it's just not hitting
that's okay take that time
and you'll find your own answers
when you say I want this but this is
stopping me and then you take that next
step to say okay here's what I should do
to address learn re-equip ask for help
to address that challenge then guess
what happens you usually do
third big idea from there you know what
fear tends to dissipate with daily
action
fear tends to dissipate with daily
action so I'd love you to do this all I
want you to do is take three steps a day
take accomplish three goals a day I know
sometimes in your life when it's really
difficult I mean I remember when in my
life when I was seriously depressed and
suicidal as a young man in college after
my girlfriend broke up with me I mean a
goal for the day might be something as
big as take a shower
literally that I mean that might have
been it take a shower eat some food talk
to a friend that that sometimes when
you're there that's that's all that's
all it takes but you can do those three
things when you're uber successful now
and you're you're breaking through it
might be call that person who you've
been waiting to call and ask for
something from shoot that video
create that product invent that thing
tell those people to stop ask for help
whatever it is find three things that
you can do every day that's appropriate
for where you're at in your life and
just do them
because you know what momentum beats the
pants out of fear the more momentum in
your life you get what we call in
Psychology the experience of the
competence confidence Loop have you
heard of that the competence confidence
loop it's a psychologically proven uh
reality where the better you get or the
more momentum you get the more
confidence and the beauty is the more
confidence you get the more you'll try
things and develop more knowledge skill
and ability thus more competence and the
more competence confidence the more
confidence these things grow together
and all sudden fear isn't such a thing
anymore because you know what you've
gotten through things before you've
broken through things before and because
you did that things change and here's
the last big idea
what's something crazy
that you could aspire to or want
crazy when you looked at your goals was
there anything on those goals that were
crazy totally Out Of Reach you're like
no way don't know how can't do that were
there anything like that I want you to
find those things I want you to write
that thing down here's three big crazy
things I want in my life then I also
want you to write here's the fear I
would have
if I chase those or I accomplished those
three big fears of if I chased it or
accomplished it because sometimes it's
not just the fears we have today it's
we're thinking we're going to have fear
tomorrow well if I go for that dream
then these things I might have fears
later on identify those and create an
action plan for those two because you
know what the more you think about your
fears the more you realize they're silly
the more you realize those worst case
scenarios almost never happen and the
more you realize you deserve something
Beyond them
you don't deserve to live a life trapped
by fear that cage of fear can only be
rattled by you only be broken by you
only be broken by your mind expanding
into new possibilities for yourself and
you taking new daily actions it's okay
to think crazy once in a while I want
something crazy and big and it's a big
goal and I don't know how I'm going to
do it don't let fear stop you get
committed to what you want
set those daily actions and quit making
the excuses that it's fear my friend it
will be the biggest breakthrough you
ever have in your life and step number
six the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is understand who
you really are with Bob Proctor do you
know that you have an image of yourself
inside
when you stand in front of a mirror you
see a reflection of the physical you
but that's not the real you you have a
picture of yourself in your mind
General Dr Maxwell maltz wrote a book
back around 1960.
it was called self-image psychology
psycho cybernetics it's a phenomenal
book he said it was the greatest
discovery of his generation
he was a cosmetic or reconstructive
surgeon and he found he would do work on
people he might have in a nose job or
removed a terrible scar
and he noticed that when he did that
there was a phenomenal change in their
personality
but he noticed with others he would make
a phenomenal physical change and there
was no change in their personality and
that led him to postulate that we have
two images we have the one that's coming
back from the mirror but we've got an
inner image and that inner self-image is
literally controlling our life you will
find people that have a very poor
self-image or low self-esteem they won't
look you straight in the eye they're
afraid to shake hands with you they're
very shy and withdrawn they go through
life hiding from Life they don't like
themselves
they don't know themself do you know
when a person improves their self-image
they change their entire life their
income change their relationship change
their health changes
and you know how you do that
start studying you start to find out
more about you there's something
phenomenal about you
do you know when I began to study this
material
57 years ago I had very poor self-image
I had low self-esteem I took dumb jobs I
never earned any money I never had fun I
had poor relationships and as I started
to study started to study real solid
information everything in my life
started to improve I've Got Friends all
over the world today I earn millions of
dollars I'm in my 80s and I get as much
energy as a person in their 30s you see
when you start to understand really who
you are you're God's highest form of
creation there's things about you that
just about blow your mind as you start
to study and really understand them
you'll walk a little taller you'll stand
a little straighter and you know
something you'll enjoy a whole lot more
of life
why is identity so important for us to
shape a positive powerful identity well
first of all so everybody understands
what I mean by identity is we all have a
way of identifying ourselves we have a
way of labeling ourselves so most of us
came up with our labels based on how we
behaved but really smart people can do
stupid things really nice people can be
mean mean people can be nice and so if
you judge yourself too soon and most
people's identity their labels for
themselves who they think they are has
been based on their past and often many
years ago and so they don't update it so
the the metaphor I give for identities
like
it's your comfort zone it's not your
goals so if you like if you took a
temperature in the room and said 68
degrees is my comfort zone physically
emotionally financially I want more in
my relationship I want more physically
energy wise I want more financially in
my career but this is what I'm used to
and so what happens people stay in their
comfort zone for the most part and then
let's say something happens and you dip
you're a 68 degree or that's your
mentality and you drop down to 62 61 60
somewhere around 60 or 59 the heaters
kick on and go whoa whoa whoa
you're 68 degree what the hell are you
doing we've all experienced that all of
a sudden you go I'm not going to live
like this anymore I'm not going to be in
this relationship I'm not going to be
fat like this how boom and you get this
drive and you start to change but what
most people don't understand
is it happens on the upper end too
meaning let's say you got momentum you
start crushing you start doing even
better than you think you go from 68 to
70 88 you're 98 Degrees financially
emotionally spiritually whatever the
metaphor is and then what happens you're
going to say Hey you bring us who the
hell do you think you are you're not a
98 degree here
all right get back to 68 and if nothing
else the heaters stop you lose your
drive and that'll drift you back and not
enough the air condition can kick on you
start to kind of sabotage yourself till
you get back to your comfort zone so
unless you expand your identity change
is temperance like when someone says to
me I stopped smoking it's been eight
days and I say why are you counting
so you can tell people how long you
lasted this time like if I went to
somebody and and I said to you hey you
know Louis you want a cigarette you're
not going to say what brand is it you go
no right I'm not a smoker notice how
people I'm not one of those that's not
my identity
identity is the strongest force in the
human personality if you look Lance
Armstrong was a mixed identity now in
the culture
this is a guy that had to win and found
a way to win it so when he was told he
had cancer in his lungs and his brain
and in his testicles and he rides a bike
and he's gonna die his answer was no I'm
a champion I find the way I will find
the answer and he did now unfortunately
he bent the rules around the sport and
it kind of ruined his reputation
obviously but that mentality his
identity is why he survived other people
told they have cancer and they're like
it's over they give up they start
arranging their Affairs and so that
psychological difference is the number
one thing I work with people on Because
unless you expand your identity you're
going to basically keep where you are
you might improve a little or not you
might go up and down a bit but you're
going to stay within a realm if you're
gonna have an explosive breakthrough to
another level physically mentally
financially spiritually then we got to
not only give you the tools we got to
shift that internal sense of who you
really are and have you find that you
are more than anything that's ever
happened to you that you can handle
whatever shows up even if it's
incredibly scary or uncomfortable if you
think that your thoughts have something
to do with your future just from
ethereum radical standpoint that your
thoughts Create Your Destiny and you
think sixty to seventy thousand thoughts
in one day and ninety percent of those
thoughts are the same thoughts as the
day before well then your life isn't
going to change very much as long as
you're thinking the same way and those
those same thoughts lead to the same
choices the same choices lead to the
same behaviors the same behaviors create
the exact same experiences and we
anticipate the same feelings or emotions
from those experiences and those
emotions are the payoff that drive our
very same thoughts well our biology our
neurosircuitry our neurochemistry our
hormones and even our gene expression
will be equal to how we think how we act
and how we feel and how we think how we
act and how we feel is called our
personality and our personality creates
our personal reality that's it so the
present personality who's listening to
this show has created the present
personal reality called their life so if
you can latch on to this idea if you
want to create a new life a new personal
reality you got to change your
personality which means you better start
thinking about what you've been thinking
about and changing it you begin to
become conscious of your unconscious
actions or habits or behaviors and
modify them
and then we have to begin to look at the
emotions that we live by every single
day
that'll keep us connected to the past
and decide do these emotions belong in
our future so most people are trying to
create a new personal reality as the
same personality and it doesn't work you
literally have to become someone else so
the principle of Neuroscience says that
nerve cells that fire together wire
together you keep thinking the same way
making the same choices demonstrating
the same habits creating the same
experiences that stamp the same networks
of neurons into the same patterns all
for the familiar feeling called you and
you do that for 10 years on end you're
going to begin to hardwire certain
patterns in your brain that becomes your
identity and by the time we're 35 years
old it kind of becomes fixed right and
psychology used to say that you can't
change that but we now know that you can
so then that kind of box in the brain
that is the habit of ourselves it's uh
we're 95 percent of the time running a
series of programs so then sitting and
doing the work we have to become
disentangled from those programs and so
the moment you decide to do something
differently or make a new choice but
most people don't want to face is that
discomfort and that that discomfort that
that uncertainty that lack of
predictability the that that that that
unknown is what people are afraid of
because they'd rather live in guilt at
least they can predict who they're going
to be then take a chance and possibility
so when a person begins to understand
this and you say well
how long have you been this way and they
say I've been like this for 35 years and
you say why 35 years because 35 years
ago I had this one event well the
stronger the emotion you feel from
reaction from that event the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
the brain Narrows its focus and freezes
the image and takes a snapshot and
that's called a memory right so then
forget the memory just overcome the
emotion because it's the emotion that
keeps you anchored to the past so that
sounds really good theoretically
but when you step out into that unknown
into that void
the body really is in a habit and what a
habit is when the body becomes the mind
or if you're thinking about that past
event and is producing an emotion well
you need an image and a feeling to start
the conditioning process so the body's
either conditioned into the familiar
past or it's hardwired in the
predictable future because it wakes up
every single day and runs through the
same series of routine actions so the
present moment then becomes the unknown
when people start feeling that
discomfort today they rather get on
their cell phone and call someone or get
up and say I can't meditate or you know
I have too much to do they excuse
themselves they return back into that
familiar feeling because the body's
actually telling the brain The Habit is
when the body becomes the mind so the
body stepping out into the unknown and
says ooh I'd rather feel guilty I'd
rather feel unhappy then be in this this
conference so then at least then when
they return back to that familiar
feeling then they feel safe so they step
out in the unknown and the body starts
influencing the mind saying you can
start tomorrow you're too busy it's your
mother's fault you know it's your
culture's fault I don't have enough
money this isn't going to work
those are the programs in there that are
standing in the way between you and your
future so then nerve cells that no
longer fire together no longer wire
together so the act of observing those
states of Mind and Body
means you're no longer the program
you're the Consciousness observing that
program so so then
to meditate it means to become familiar
with so as you become familiar with
those thoughts you become conscious of
how you speak you become aware of how
you act you notice how you're feeling
the more conscious you become of those
unconscious programs the less
unconscious you'll go in your waking day
why because it's not enough to just have
a great meditation and get up and get on
the freeway and get in traffic and
getting stressed you just return back to
the old self again our job then
is to sustain that modified State of
Mind and Body the entire day and if you
can get ready because something
different or unusual is going to begin
to happen in your life and it will come
as a coincidence or a synchronicity and
that's breadcrumbs from the Divine
saying you're on the path just keep
doing it there'll be another one just
keep staying in that energy and so
teaching people then to understand that
there's a formula that we now know that
if you apply that formula you'll begin
to see those changes and now as people
are doing it more and more
effectively the results are going up as
well we just had Bond University they
just took a whole bunch of my brain
scans from 10 years ago
huge clinical study a lot of analysis
and and they're Blown Away by the speed
in which
the community can change brain or hard
coherence they they know how to do it
it's not uh something that's that's
separate from them they've practiced it
enough times that they they now know how
to do it so what's the significance of
that well really simple in your life
if you start returning back to the same
reactions to the same people and
circumstances you're returning back to
the old self so you got to stay
conscious in your life and and if you're
not being defined by a vision of the
future then you're left with the
memories of the past and you will be
predictable in your life so Crossing
that River of change from the old self
to the new self there's a neurological a
biological chemical hormonal a genetic
death of the old self but if you teach
people there's something on the other
side they won't give up on themselves
they'll keep going so there's enough
evidence to encourage people and you
can't tell me you're too old to do this
work you can't tell me you're too sick
to do this work he can't tell me you had
a turbulent past or or that you're too
overweight or too underweight or too out
of shape or you can't even tell me that
you've never meditated before in fact
some of our greatest
Gans or people who just have never
meditated before that are not trying to
do anything they just follow
instructions so
our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible and they
go all in not 50 in not sixty percent
and when we do a week-long event we got
a thousand people or 1500 people and
they are all in and that when they start
getting Beyond themselves that first day
or second day once they start getting
Beyond themselves and that magic starts
to happen then I have no idea I can't
predict what's going to happen next and
it's usually pretty pretty exciting to
change your life you have to be willing
to change your actions
the definition of insanity is doing the
same thing over and over and over again
and expecting a different result
if you want to change your life you want
to be in a different spot you have to be
doing different things now if you love
your life great don't change anything or
you love pieces of your life don't
change anything about those pieces but
if you are not happy with where you are
at you must be able be willing to do
different things otherwise you will stay
stuck forever I was doing an Instagram
live yesterday with a young entrepreneur
he wants to be a speaker and he wants to
share his message and he's constantly
facing self-doubt and fear and
insecurity and nobody's watching the
stories and he's not good enough and who
am I to share a message in in our IG
live one of the things he said was
well I'm not I'm not comfortable doing
that
we're talking about making making
content some days he's on top of the
world and feels great and other days
he's not and he doesn't feel comfortable
getting in front of the camera
and he started going off and telling me
a story stop right there
when you say I'm not comfortable doing
that
we have to identify that as a trigger to
go
saying I'm not comfortable doing that
now if it's against your values I get it
right you're not comfortable you know
I'm at Costco right now Nina's going
shopping in there I'm not comfortable
robbing Costco perfect okay that's
outside my value system that's totally
different most of the things that you're
not comfortable doing
are failing in front of other people
at the end of the day it's what it is
you're afraid of being judged and so
we're not comfortable doing that thing
you'll you'll fail if nobody else sees
it if it's just you but you don't want
to fail in front of other people and
that can no longer be a good enough
reason because if you only do think
about this if you only do what's
comfortable
you stay in your comfort zone
if you only do what's comfortable
you stay in your comfort zone
and therefore you hate your life
because if all you did is wake up and do
what's in your comfort zone do what is
known do what is comfortable do what do
what you've always done you're going to
hate your life and this becomes the
curse of a lot of entrepreneurs is you
know you're capable of more you know you
want to do more you know you have more
in your heart to go up and serve you you
want that you can you can see you can
touch it you can taste it you can
visualize it like I want to be there I
want to do that right has that happened
to you can that relate to you
you know you want more but you're afraid
to go off and do it and and you fall
back down to comfort at least
consistently you might have these
moments of greatness and boldness and
willingness to go do something but we
fall back down to comfort
and if you stay in comfort you will
never accomplish your great goals
because everything you want out of life
is on the other side of your comfort
zone
everything you want out of life
all your big goals your Big Dreams your
big Ambitions your mission the life that
you want the life that you want is on
the other side of your comfort zone and
so I had to stop him when he was talking
to me on the Instagram live because it
doesn't matter if you're not comfortable
doing it
is actually the opposite because you are
uncomfortable doing it now you have to
do it
because you need to train yourself that
you do uncomfortable things the fact
that you have accepted
being uncomfortable as a good enough
reason to stop is the big problem I
don't care what else you're gonna what
other Story You're gonna tell me
afterwards I have to stop the
conversation at that moment because I
could not allow him to continue with the
mindset of I'm uncomfortable so I'm
going to stop
and we all have these words that we tell
ourselves and we all have these stories
that we come back to as to why we're not
able to take action and the problem is
we believe those things and you need to
catch them and you need to root them out
and so for him that was the big aha
moment
that he needs to get uncomfortable and
it sounds
it doesn't sound like a big deal right
like oh of course you got to get
uncomfortable but what is the thing that
you're telling yourself as to why you're
not winning as to why you can't follow
through as to why you can't do the thing
and when somebody else shines a light on
it it's like it seems so obvious
and yet this is a thing that has been
holding you back and keeping you stuck
so I told him
anytime you hear yourself say
this makes me uncomfortable again as
long as it's not against your value
system right this makes me feel
uncomfortable
use it as a trigger to go forward
enlist your family he's newly married
enlist your wife enlist your parents
enlist your siblings anytime somebody
hears you say
that makes me feel uncomfortable that's
that's a trigger go have them have them
hold you accountable said you just said
it again now you got to go do that thing
as that's not against your value system
right
for me it's scary difficult and hard
I would accept
scary difficult or hard as good enough
reasons for me not to go off and do the
thing that I want him to do
I want to make videos oh that's scary
like oh okay I can't do it
I've just accepted scary as a good
enough reason
and so if I never do things that are
scary I will never accomplish my big
goals
when um
you know when I when I was thinking
about doing my tour in 2019 we had 23
cities 90 days
I thought that was too difficult
too difficult you know like I'm I was
afraid to get on stage and here I am not
facing my fear every four days in a new
city I've never done a tour and instead
of just doing a small tour of three
cities or something like 23 cities 90
days you know a quarter of a year on the
road straight with with my wife and my
cameraman
okay let's go
because I do difficult things because I
want to train myself that I do difficult
things
because again my dream life is on the
other side of me doing difficult things
if I only do what's easy
I'm gonna eventually hate my life
this is where we get stuck
you know when you do something that's
easy
and you win you win a little Ribbon or
an award right you you run a race
against three-year-olds and you win
congratulations amazing you won and you
could post about on Instagram and you
had this little moment of Accolade but
you don't actually feel good about
yourself because you didn't do anything
difficult because that was easy for you
the self-love self-confidence
self-respect comes from doing difficult
things
uncomfortable things scary things hard
things
the willingness to show up even if you
don't win
[Music]
because it's difficult and challenging
that's how you ultimately will win in
life
and start to accomplish your goals and
so
most people are photocopying their lives
this is this is where most people are
stuck you're photocopying your life
today looked the same as yesterday look
the day is the day before same as the
day before is why most people do not
like their life is why most people drive
to a job that they hate
they're driving to a job to the hate
most people wake up all you know look at
all these cars here most people here in
this parking lot they're picking up
every day and driving to a job that they
hate they do not like their life most of
the people who are telling you what you
should do with your life do not like
their own life
and so the answer is to catch your
trigger words so I call them play bigger
triggers
what's a play bigger trigger what are
your trigger words what do you say think
about one of your goals
you know think about what's on your list
of to-do's think about where you want to
be you know what do you have to get done
what's one of your most important goals
right now that you've been
procrastinating on
what have you been delaying on there's
something
everybody's got something
what's the goal of yours that you've
been sitting on and then what's the
voice in your head that that's giving
you an acceptable reason for you not to
do the thing now try to get to the
reason behind the reason
so example somebody wants to make
YouTube videos I want to I want to be a
thought leader I have a message in my
heart I want to get it out to the world
awesome what's the reason why you're
telling yourself you can't do it like oh
well I know the time I don't have the
camera I don't have the gear I don't
have the microphone I don't know what to
say uh all of these those are the
practical reasons right those are not
the real reasons the real reason is
buried underneath the Practical reasons
why do you think that having the right
camera and microphone is going to be the
difference well because you're actually
afraid of judgment you're afraid that
people are going to watch it
we're afraid of when people won't watch
it and what does that mean you know that
you suck and the people will watch it
and laugh at you or criticize you for
having a bad phone bad camera bad
microphone
or they can't hear you or whatever else
like you're afraid of judgment
underneath the reason of
I don't have a good enough camera
microphone Etc
is just fear
and the fear specifically is judgment
so think about your own goals
what do you want to do what have you
been delaying on what have you been
procrastinating on what's the reason
you're telling yourself
The Logical one the one that you're
buying and then what's the reason
underneath the reason
what's the actual reason
and that's your trigger
so if it's fear of judgment if it's fear
failure if it's fear of not being good
enough if the fear of being imposter if
it's fear of being uncomfortable
whatever your actual fear is that's your
trigger
and that is holding you back not just in
this one goal but in life in everything
in all your goals it's the reason why
you're not taking action across all your
goals
and so now when you can catch it
and then take the action to say I am the
person who does difficult things I am
the person who gets uncomfortable I am
the person who's going to change my
actions because that's the only way I'm
going to get the life that I want
when you can catch it specifically
it shortcuts the brain
because at least for me and I've seen it
work for many other people when you've
when you've accepted comfort for example
as a reason why you can't take action
and then you hear yourself say well that
makes me uncomfortable
now you have to do it you just have to
do it you take the brain out of the
equation now the reasons don't matter
you said uncomfortable so now I have to
go and do it period
so catch what your trigger word is and
I'd love to even know in in the comments
below if you want to leave what is your
trigger word that when you say it when
you text it when you think it when you
feel it that has been holding you back
and that you no longer wanted to
so let's put it in the chat and let's
relieve
a little bit of that pressure that that
word holds over us
so you can actually go build the life
that you want you don't have to
necessarily have done anything wrong for
things to get completely out of control
it's a terrifying Doctrine but it's not
a hopeless Doctrine because it still
says that there's a way forward there's
a pathway forward and the pathway
forward is to adopt a mode of being that
has some nobility so that you can
tolerate yourself and perhaps even have
some respect for yourself as someone
who's capable of standing up in the face
of that terrible vulnerability and
suffering and that the pathway forward
as far as the existentialists are
concerned is by well certainly by the
avoidance of Deceit particularly in
language but also by the adoption of
responsibility for the conditions of
existence and some attempt on your part
to actually Rectify them and the thing
that's so interesting about that is
there we have two as far as I'm
concerned
and some of this is from Clinical
experience you know if you take people
and I've told you this and you expose
them voluntarily to things that they are
avoiding and are afraid of you know that
they know they need to overcome in order
to meet their goals their self-defined
goals if you can teach people to stand
up in the face of the things they're
afraid of they get stronger
and you don't know what the upper limits
to that are because you might ask
yourself like if for 10 years if you
didn't avoid doing what you knew you
needed to do by the deaf by your own
definitions right within the value
structure that you've created to the
degree that you've done that what would
you be like
well you know there are remarkable
people who come into the world from time
to time and there are people who do find
out over decades long periods what they
could be like if they were who they were
if they said if they spoke their being
forward
and they get stronger and stronger and
stronger and we don't know the limits to
that we do not know the limits to that
and so you could say well in part
perhaps the reason that you're suffering
unbearably can be left at your feet
because you're not everything you could
be and you know it and of course that's
a terrible thing to admit and it's a
terrible thing to consider but there's
real promise in it right because it
means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world in a number
another way that you could act in the
world so what it would reflect back to
you would be much better than what it
reflects back to you now my experience
is with people that we're probably
running at about 51 percent of our
capacity something I mean you can think
about this yourselves I often ask
undergraduates
how many hours a day you waste or how
many hours a week you waste and the
classic answer is something like four to
six hours a day you know inefficient
studying watching things on YouTube that
not only do you not want to watch that
you don't even care about that make you
feel horrible about watching after
you're done that's probably four hours
right there you know what you think well
that's 20 25 hours a week it's 100 hours
a month that's two and a half full work
weeks it's half a year of work weeks per
year and if your time is worth
twenty dollars an hour which is a
radical underestimate it's probably more
like 50 if you think about it in terms
of deferred wages if you're wasting 20
hours a week you're wasting 50 000 a
year and you are doing that right now
and it's because you're young wasting
fifty thousand dollars a year is a way
bigger catastrophe than it would be for
me to waste it because I'm not going to
last nearly as long and so if your life
isn't everything it could be you could
ask yourself well what would happen if
you just stopped wasting the
opportunities that are in front of you
you be who knows how much more efficient
10 times more efficient 20 times more
efficient that's the Pareto distribution
you have no idea how efficient efficient
people get it's completely it's off the
charts
well and if we all got our act together
collectively and stop making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time not only do they
not do what they should to make things
better they actively attempt to make
things worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or
or homicidal or genocidal or all of
those things all
bundled together in an absolutely
pathological package if people stopped
really really trying just to make things
worse we have no idea how much better
they would get just because of that
so there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability social
judgment both of which are are are our
major causes of suffering and the
failure of individuals to adopt the
responsibility that they know they
should adopt it isn't merely that your
fate depends on whether or not you get
your act together and to what degree you
decide that you're going to live out
your own genuine being it isn't only
your fate it's the fate of everyone that
you're networked with and so you know
you think well there's nine billion
seven billion people in the world we're
going to Peak at about 9 billion by the
way and then it'll decline rapidly but
seven billion people in the world and
who are you you're just one little dust
moat among that seven billion and so it
really doesn't matter what you do or
don't do but that's simply not the case
it's the wrong model because you're at
the center of a network you're a node in
a network of course that's even more
true now that we have social media
you'll you'll know a thousand people at
least over the course of your life and
they'll know a thousand people each and
that puts you one person away from a
million and two persons away from a
billion
and so that's how you're connected and
the things you do they're like dropping
a stone in a pond the ripples move
outward and they affect things in ways
that you can't fully comprehend and it
means that the things that you do and
that you don't do are far more important
than you think
and so if you act that way of course the
terror of realizing that is that it
actually starts to matter what you do
and you might say well that's better
than living a meaningless existence it's
better for it to matter but I mean if
you really ask yourself would you be so
sure if you had the choice I can live
with no responsibility whatsoever the
price I pay is that nothing matters
or I can reverse it and everything
matters
but I have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that it's not so
obvious to me that people would take the
meaningful path
now when you say well nihilists suffered
dreadfully because there's no meaning in
their life and they still suffer yeah
but the advantage is they have no
responsibility
so that's the payoff and I actually
think that's the motivation say well I
can't help being nihilistic all my
belief systems have collapsed it's like
yeah maybe
maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out and the
price you pay is a meaningless suffering
but you can always whine about that and
people will feel sorry for you and you
have the option of taking the pathway of
the Martyr so that's a pretty good deal
All Things Considered especially when
they are when the alternative is to
bear your burden properly and to live
forthrightly in the world well with
sojournitzen figured out and so many
people in the 20th century it's not just
him even though he's the best example is
that if you live a pathological life you
pathologize your society and if enough
people do that then it's hell
really
really
and you can read the gulag archipelago
if you have the fortitude to do that and
you'll see exactly what hell is like and
then you can decide if that's a place
you'd like to visit or even more
importantly if it's a light if it's a
place you'd like to visit and take all
your family and friends because that's
what happened in the 20th century
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to change your brain to change your
life with John astrap check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there there's a misconception that
business is easy
and I have a lot of clients of mine for
example that are there are doctors and
lawyers and professionals